il est 7 heures du matin au mont saint
michel bazin touristes à l'horizon
pourtant ils viennent galles ton 70 ans
est déjà sur le pont
l'adjoint au maire vient d'être appelé
en urgence
bonjour speed il ya toujours des
problèmes aussi il ce matin le problème
est de taille une odeur nauséabonde
vient d'envahir la rue ça serai là à peu
près
d'accord
chez un commerçant la canalisation des
toilettes a cassé il faut trouver d'où
vient la fuite mais aujourd'hui on tire
les pavés en creuse
ce qui stresse sienne guelton sait
comment faire passer les touristes avec
ces travaux les premiers vont arriver
dans trois heures on va faire les
essayer de deviner dans la
laisse un petit passage
en pleine saison les touristes peuvent
être jusqu'à 20000 chaque jour à
emprunter cette petite rue la seule qui
mène à l'abbaye autant dire qu'on
interrompe à le trafic pour moi un
objectif
primordial que ce soit toujours voilà
c'est comme ça aux boys on gère faut que
cela deux jours ouvert
mais dans ses rues étroites du moyen-âge
cela va prendre un peu de temps
l'adjoint commencent à s'inquiéter la
mer d'abord
égalé celle de me rappelle vite fait
s'il te plaît d'urgence parce que je
suis vraiment amer
a pris trois heures de travaux
impossible de trouver cette maudite
fuite est le premier groupe de touristes
arrivent déjà des japonais mais pas
question pour autant de se montrer
stressé il faut faire bonne figure
bonjour en japonais
[Rires]
les touristes sont obligés de se
faufiler pour continuer leur parcours
non non je laisse passer
un coup dur en pleine saison pour
l'image du mont saint michel
un des sites les plus visités au monde
[Musique]
rocher d'un kilomètre carré le mont
saint michel est un trait d'union entre
la bretagne et la normandie
un site exceptionnel classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco connu et
reconnu pour son joyau l'abbaye du mont
saint michel
déjà dès le 14e siècle on y venait en
pèlerinage comme à rome ou à saint
jacques de compostelle
aujourd'hui le mont-saint-michel attire
chaque année 3 millions de touristes du
monde entier
après paris c'est le deuxième site le
plus visité de france
depuis une semaine la famille o'byrne
marche à travers chants accompagnés de
taquin un âne du poitou il a sauté près
de 20 kilomètres par jour mais ce matin
david and et leurs trois enfants
touchent leur but presque du doigt
regardez comme le paysage non valeur le
bon sens garder les enfants il est là
voilà le mont saint michel vous le voyez
bien
à portée de main le mont-saint-michel
leur terre promise
plus on se rapproche et non plus les
monumentales c'est ça qui est
impressionnant
elle est très beau
en louant se tanne cette famille
lyonnais tu voulais revivre l'épopée des
pèlerins d'antan et la plus que quelques
kilomètres avant d'atteindre leur but
mais ce matin ce n'est pas capucine cinq
ans ou joséphine six ans qui traîne la
patte mais taquin qui fait sa tête de
mule
ok
[Musique]
allez on y va
au casting
après 120 km de marche et des nuits
passées à la belle étoile la famille a
hâte d'arriver mais elle va vite
déchanter
bienvenue dans la civilisation
après sept jours de solitude et
davanture nous voilà arrivés dans un
milieu urbain
au pied du mont l'ambiance n'est pas
celle des pèlerins du moyen âge mais aux
milliers de touristes équipés
d'appareils photo
la famille devient carrément
l'attraction
ça c'est plus du concours lancé pour le
touriste
c'est vous attention annales
voilà pour taquin c'est la fin du voyage
bonjour aujourd'hui
question sécurité il faudra rester ici
d'incarner très bien absolument à dakar
tous les ouvriers amène bas ici c'est
pas pour en ont assez exceptionnel nous
mêmes
après avoir rendu service à toute la
famille taquin fini son périple dans ce
camion remorque
il repart avec son propriétaire
dans l'unique et étroite rue du monde le
pire est à venir
difficile d'avancer c'est
l'embouteillage sur 300 m bien loin de
la paix intérieure qu'ils étaient venus
chercher
seule solution pour s'extirper de cette
marée humaine c'est de prendre de la
hauteur et de gravir les 350 marche qui
mène à l'abbaye du mont saint michel
un parcours très sportif un tiers des
touristes abandonne en chemin mais au
sommet
une vue imprenable sur la baie du mont
saint michel
si l'on fait tous ces kilomètres c'est
pour admirer le joyau du rocher l'abbaye
un monastère millénaire empreint
d'histoire
c'est saint-aubert c'est l'évêque
d'avranches
donc joséphine vient de prendre
saint-aubert l'évêque d'avranches en
photo
l'évêque saint-aubert si le
mont-saint-michel existe c'est un peu
grâce à lui
comme le rappelle ce vitrail en 708
c'est évêque aurait reçu l'ordre de
l'archange saint-michel de construire
sur le monde un édifice à la gloire de
dieu au bout du troisième rappel il fini
par s'exécuter et ordonne la
construction de l'abbaye
le rocher de granit fut alors appelé
mont saint michel
une merveille de l'occident mais surtout
une sacrée source de tracas pour jan
galle ton l'adjoint au maire nous le
retrouvons 150 mètres plus bas à lui
tendue que jamais comme un élève avant
une interro à bages arrive je descends
je suis à vous il a rendez vous avec un
homme qui ne plaisante pas avec le
patrimoine c'est l'architecte des
bâtiments de france monsieur germaine
le mont saint michel va être passée au
crible toute transformation des
bâtiments doit être validé par
l'architecte et l'homme et du genre
pointilleux
oui pour la pour bat pour la
restauration
des couleurs des façades au choix des
tuiles jusqu'à l'emplacement précis des
gouttières
l'élève galt on se fait remonter les
bretelles
rien n'échappe à l'architecte qui ne
veut voir que du style médiéval
alors quand il tombe sur ce
défibrillateur en plastique il est au
bord de la crise cardiaque
ça c'est la limite du système
le défibrillateur apparent ça me paraît
beaucoup c'est
vrai c'est bon goût ces propos c'est pas
bon mais c'est obligatoire c'est quand
même si on était capable de trouver
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
discret d'un peu plus élégant et de le
dégager par rapport à la lecture de
l'architecturé de la maison sucden
un détail par rapport au reste le vrai
problème ce sont les commerçants qui
prennent certaines libertés
colas activités perso
dans la rue principale les pancartes
publicitaires se sont multipliés c'est à
celui qui aura la plus grosse et ça ça
ne convient pas du tout à monsieur
germaine donc je vois cette enseigne est
là et comme je vois un deux trois sur le
même endroit quatre fers le même endroit
il ya un problème
que le mot soit
une aire commerçante membres évident que
les gens viennent aussi chercher ça je
vienne pas chercher du moche
face à ces remontrances l'adjoint au
maire en caisse obligé de jouer les
fayots
ah mais je suis entièrement d'accord moi
je j'aime bien que le mont-saint-michel
soit clean présent présentable
et pour monsieur guelton le supplice est
loin d'être terminée quelques mètres
plus loin les commerçants se sont étalés
sur les murs de l'église alors là
l'architecte voit rouge la sanction est
immédiate
je pense qu'il faut qu'on les fasse
décroche irak
l'heure du grand ménage a sonné et une
fois de plus c'est l'adjoint au maire
qui va s'y coller ce qui ne l'enchanté
pas vraiment
moi je vais avoir des gros problèmes
après parce que tous les commerçants qui
vont tomber dessus je vous dire que ça
va être costaud germaine ou plaisir
le problème c'est que si les commerçants
ne transige pas ils s'exposent à des
amendes
alors pour les convaincre l'adjoint au
maire il va sur la pointe des pieds
il tente sa chance avec madame frameries
la vendeuse de souvenirs
je peux voir deux petites secondes de
jeu germaine impressions photos oui
parce que ça le perforer veut pas voir
ça il veut voir ces pierres par contre
je suis d'accord avec lui mais sauf que
ça ce sont des articles qui sont loués
sans associer losc 8 et donc si vous
mettez une grille en face
à ce repas est pris sur une grille en
ferrain j'aimerais quand même froid pour
ce que germaine et comme du souci est
qu'il ya un client qui reçoivent les
gargouilles conso objet d'attaqués me
surprennent c'est quand même dommage
madame frameries joue l'ironie car ici
l'architecte ne fait pas peur il y en a
deux en particulier qui ne se laisse pas
faire les restaurateurs au franc parler
légendaire
frédéric fidèle dit fredo et sa femme a
même supplanté par deux compagnies la
wii
avec l'embellie sur l'ami préféré à nani
j'ai passé lien bon de voir les façades
en pierre
et moi je sais combien moi je l'aimé le
charme monsieur qui montrent la rue du
mont saint michel je veux pas que ceci
je compte cela je côtoie civils gazaouis
civic si c'est pas moi c'est près du
mont saint michel
fredo personne ne viendra jamais lui
donner d'ordres dans sa boutique je sais
pas
s'il pousse trop à bout un jour ça va
péter ça va péter
voilà
la bombe et presto plancher de trois ans
mais trois ans quatre ans comme
ici le commerce fait loi aujourd'hui le
mont saint michel est devenue une usine
à touristes où tout est fait pour vendre
c'est un peu ce que va découvrir notre
petite famille de marcheurs
après la visite de l'abbaye passage
obligé à la boutique de souvenirs
réclamé par les enfants
[Musique]
comme des millions de touristes année
david vont être obligés de mettre la
main au portefeuille
[Musique]
jolie qui ressemble au mont-saint-michel
là c'est pas le mont saint michel c'est
un pélican mon coeur mais qu'elle se
rassure ici elle a l'embarras du choix
tu as l effigie du rocher à 8 euros dé à
coudre à 5 euros donc décoratives pour 4
euros ou encore déléguant cadran
coquillages à 14 euros
le mont-saint-michel inspire
et madame frameries la patronne a
toujours la dernière nouveauté qui peut
faire plaisir celle ci qui est avec un
baril mais il n'y a pas la neige par
contre c'est avec la marée comme ça
devant et là ça fait porte-crayons pas
mal
c'est trop long je ne pourrais pas mais
j'aime bien le kitsch mais modérément
mais peu importe il faut ramener un
souvenir du monde je vais prendre des
cartes postales
les enfants eux en profitent pour en
rajouter un peu plus dans le panier
la panoplie chabrac celle bull
tu la trouves elle
avait paya lâche aussi
rien à voir avec le mont saint michel
mais comme la plupart des parents année
david finissent par céder au total entre
le kitsch riz et les épées de chevalier
le couple s'en sort tout de même pour 57
euros 20 ses enfants qui ont fait cet
effort
non sa faute en or quel coût
[Musique]
chaque année trois millions de visiteurs
viennent remplir les tiroirs caisses des
commerçants
80 millions d'euros de retombées
touristiques que se partagent un parti
une dizaine de familles historiques du
monde bien assise sur leur tas d'or
[Musique]
le lendemain midi au mont saint michel
nous retrouvons frédéric fidèles le
restaurateur au franc parler
what a fallu corriger
ce cuisinier de 53 ans ça dépote
un sauté demont plus d'infos pékin
avec sa femme et sa fille il prépare
jusqu'à 120 couverts chaque musique
dans une cuisine de quatre mètres carrés
et pas moyen de s'agrandir car comme
tous les autres commerces du monde son
restaurant été construit à même le
rocher oui c'est ça tu aies croisé
carrément dans le rocher donc on voit
que le rocher ici l'eau et coule de
partout ça cool ici aussi les gens ils
sont en signant ici il croit que sa
dignité si les dix écoles bénéficier
vous avez dans l'expérience et de
rochers sa famille est installée sur le
monde depuis
1783 huit générations et il n'est pas
peu fier lacer mes aïeux se mon arrière
arrière grand père
frédéric vidal ancien maire du mont
saint-michel frédéric vidal moi je
m'appelle frédérick raynal aussi avec
son épouse son patrimoine vaut de l'or
alors fredo s'y accrochent férocement et
des tests ce qui si on appelle les hauts
revenus ne pas de hors jeu
alors venu vous êtes quelqu'un qui vient
de l'extérieur proches et chez nous on
vend les affaires entre nous si on a à
vendre sinon c'est de famille en famille
façon c'est de famille en famille ou de
génération en génération
une histoire de famille dans l'étroite
rue du mont quasiment tous ses voisins
sont des cousins
à deux pas de son restaurant sa cousine
géraldine tient ce magasin de souvenirs
cela fait de la soeur de mon père
[Musique]
un peu plus bas marie-pierre elle s'est
spécialisée dans les crêpes cela fait le
frère de mon père
encore un
[Musique]
joli col une bonne ambiance et les
familles unies en apparence seulement
board de focus planque que notre grande
famille c'est une famille avec lui
plusieurs clans
en réalité les familles se livrent une
guerre commerciale sans pitié sur 300
mètres près de 50 commerces collés les
uns aux autres se disputent la manne
touristique
c'est comme la série dallas
toutes les familles à gauche et à droite
qui tire dans les pattes et qui ne
disent pas ce qu'ils pensent
le mont saint michel un univers
impitoyable digne du feuilleton dallas
comme dans la série le rocher à son jr
l'homme de pouvoir que tout le monde
jalouse eric vannier 60 ans
berline de luxe cheveux gominés bon
remercie
l'homme règne en maître sur le monde et
le pire pour les natifs c'est qu'il
n'est même pas du rocher à part des
vacances scolaires passées ici il a
toujours vécu à paris
aujourd'hui c'est pourtant le maire du
mont saint michel mais c'est surtout un
redoutable homme d'affaires
depuis trente ans il profiterait des
dissensions familiales pour acheter un
par un tous les commerces de l'île à un
certain nombre oui
à gauche à droite devant derrière
les avril
et là aussi c'est à une auberge et un
hôtel reçu
des hôtels des restaurants mais pas
seulement aux gens ça vient
aussi oui
au début ce sont des musées le mont
saint michel ils jouent les blasés mais
eric vannier possède en réalité un
véritable empire plus de vingt
établissements un tiers des commerces de
l'île mais son coup de maître c'est
d'avoir mis la main sur le restaurant le
plus convoité du rocher il se trouve un
peu plus bas à l'entrée du monde la mère
poulard un restaurant aussi célèbre que
le rocher lui même renommé pour cette
omelette
battu en rythme sa préparation est un
spectacle pour les passants
[Musique]
batteur de père en fils
un des piliers de la maison
une omelette bien mousseuse qui attire
des curieux du monde entier et pour
laquelle il faut quand même débourser 39
euros alors à ce prix là il vaut mieux
qu'elle soit bonne
les fabuleux
ça fait cher de l'oeuf cette omelette a
pourtant l'air simple à préparer des
oeufs du beurre le tout cuit au feu de
bois et un petit plus tenu secret
ça ne ment pas à la recette elle est à
la fois dans ma tête et dans un coffre
fort pour celui qui voudrait me couper
la tête
eric banny m entretenir le mystère
pourtant il n'a rien inventé cette
omelette a été créé en 1888 par un petit
bout de femme annette poulard
[Musique]
à l'époque pour a saisi les pèlerins la
famille après un long voyage cette
ancienne bonne leur prépare une omelette
bien mousseuse
[Musique]
sa cuisine et sa réputation font vite le
tour du monde et l'auberge devient le
symbole gastronomique du mont saint
michel
dans les années 80 eric vannier a fait
fortune en rachetant des célèbres boîtes
de nuit parisiennes comme le palace où
les bains douches et quand l'auberge de
la mère poulard est à vendre il met le
paquet pour l'obtenir
qu'à l'époque il y avait trois
possibilités un groupe américain groupe
japonais moi donc je pensais qu'il
fallait quand même ça reste un peu
français voilà tout simplement donc j'ai
j'ai cassé beaucoup cassé ma tirelire
qui était pas grosse à l'époque et j'ai
essayé de la voir c'est un peu ce joyau
du mont saint michel
et éric gagné est un homme d'affaires
redoutable il va faire de la mère
poulard une véritable marque et
multiplier les produits dérivés
[Musique]
cookies et à l'aide bretonne confiture
caramel mais aussi celle de guérande
sardines en boîte et même thé anglais
battre et locales
moi que tout est fait pour des
personnages connaissent pas très bien
les régions
les différentes contrées françaises
aujourd'hui la petite aubert s'est
transformé en un groupe agroalimentaire
qui emploie plus de 1000 personnes
eric vannier possède même sa propre
usine à 20 km du rocher et l'homme
d'affaires en veut toujours plus tant de
jours il a prévu d'exporter sa marque à
l'autre bout du monde
un business qui lui laisse peu de temps
pour gérer au quotidien ses fonctions de
maire alors il délègue à jan galle ton
son adjoint
d'etc août une bonne façon d'éviter les
natifs du rocher
il est plus accepter parce que pour les
montois et les plus montois que moi
voilà donc voilà c'est tout et puis
voilà c'est chacun chacun sa croix
absolument
absolument qu'un élément comme ça
[Rires]
une fonction loin d'être de tout repos
pour l'adjoint
car depuis quelques années la colère
gronde au mont saint michel
le lendemain matin c'est à ponte en sont
à 9 km du mont que nous retrouvons
frédéric ridel le natif et grand
amoureux du rocher
grâce aux recettes de son restaurant il
a pu s'offrir cette maison moderne 250
m² ici fini les vieilles pierres
c'est carrelage du sol au plafond comme
tous les autres commerçants fredo
n'habite plus sur le rocher si on a
habité pendant des années il ya aussi
quelques inconvénients
donc j'allais prendre les enfants à
l'école et pas de ramassage scolaire est
le pur une pompe qui avaient pu l'école
donc le mont-saint-michel boucle
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de vie de
village sur le mont seulement des
commerces à l'heure du café le journal
local donne encore du grain à moudre à
fredo le râleur on y parle des grands
changements en cours face en ce moment à
voir le jour de mon sens du chardon peut
il dit se montent les gens sont pas
contents
des mécontents car le monde est au coeur
d'un chantier pharaonique
dix ans de travaux 230 millions d'euros
un ouvrage titanesque mais nécessaire
car au fil du temps à cause des
sédiments le mont s'est ensablé pour
qu'il redevienne une île en 2006 on a
construit un barrage qui rejettent les
sédiments large aujourd'hui on construit
un nouveau pont pour y accéder et pour
que le paysage me ressemble plus à ça un
énorme parking l'accès au mont est
désormais strictement interdite aux
voitures et c'est justement ce qui fait
râler fredo il se sent tout bonnement
étrangers en son pays c'est la nouvelle
barrière qu'ils ont faits nous ont bien
maintenant on rentre sur notre parc
d'attractions donc là on est
complètement parquet peut plus rentrer
chez nous on peut bien les chaînes comme
on veut faut qu'on passe par une
barrière commande pas blanche et qui
n'attend est limitée à 30 km heure sur
cette route là
ça c'est pas oui enfin bon
désormais au mont saint michel tout le
monde doit se garer sur ces parkings
situés à deux kilomètres et demi du site
les visiteurs doivent ensuite prendre
une de ses navettes pour arriver au but
fredo lui laisse ça aux touristes en
tant que commerçant il a laissé passer
valable uniquement pour les livraisons
mais fredo en profite pour se garer au
pied du mont toute la journée ce qui est
totalement illégal
non circoncis mais quand même
cinq six voitures de genre du mont saint
michel qui sont là dans la journée avant
une quinzaine 15 récalcitrants
à une prune du 7 euros j'ai arrêté de
fumer comme ça ça va être une surtout
à cause des travaux la guerre est
ouverte sur le monde entre la
municipalité certains commerçants des
irréductibles
et comme d'habitude c'est l'adjoint au
maire jan galle ton qui va au front
[Musique]
e
ce jour là il doit faire voter la
construction d'un nouvel accès au mont
une sortie de secours en cas de grandes
marées problème il va falloir percée à
droite de cet échafaudage dans le rocher
et ça c'est un sacrilège pour certains
en toi on ne doit pas toucher à leurs
cailloux
alors à quelques heures du conseil
municipal il se fait alpaguer dans la
rue par les anti travaux
c'est génial s'est jamais
classé à l'unesco ont été
signalés au mont saint michel c'est au
mont saint michel au moyen âge il ya eu
la même politique que maintenant le
mont-saint-michel leur était jamais
construit à cette époque là alors
ok bon bain kutwa tout leur dira alors
là cet après midi ça va être costaud
l'intérim est un gilet pare balles
sans gilet pare balles mais avec
beaucoup de détermination
l'adjoint au maire va affronter le
conseil municipal composé exclusivement
de commerçants du monde comme géraldine
faliez une montoise pas commode logique
c'est la cousine de fredo
c'est horrible c'est horrible ce un
crime en
temps réel la plus tenace opposante aux
travaux mallem le break l'une des rares
habitants du mont
il est à suivre au chai à la commune à
la commune alors s'il a la commune mais
la commune
et la sortie on va en parler on va en
parler le ton est donné
alors je vais vous présenter la demande
d'autorisation travaux très vite
géraldine failli interrompt l'adjoint il
faut gagner du temps parce que c'est un
jeu des habitants alors là si on veut
tous contre ce qui se passe le préfet
rappelant la vessie parce que ça va
retarder les choses
c'est le délire seulement voilà autour
de la table les conseillers anti travaux
sont minoritaires alors qui est contre
eux cette autorisation demandé par la
drac
alors
un contre qui et pour
jet de voir
messieurs la séance est levée
la majorité
les travaux sont votés une partie du
rocher sera bien détruites pour
construire une issue de secours au monde
nous liberté son profit ce qui est ici
c'est une honte
yatuu ne peut pas dire que tu aimes le
monde qui n'aiment pas le montueux puis
à voter la destruction du rocher c'est
honteux 20 sur 10 n y pas dire le
contraire
c'est honteux de
messieurs dames au plaisir
après une lutte sans merci la bataille
du jour et gagner pour l'adjoint au
maire et l'équipe municipale
mais pour les habitants il y a un grand
absent monsieur le maire
bien loin du mont saint michel à dix
mille kilomètres de là c'est au japon
que nous retrouvons eric vannier
monsieur le maire est avant tout un
homme d'affaires
il a décidé d'exporter sa marque dans ce
pays de 128 millions d'habitants il en
est persuadé l'image de la mère poulard
peut séduire ici c'est un pays test
avant d'aller conquérir l'asie
ce matin il va inaugurer son nouveau
restaurant loin des vieilles pierres du
monde dans cette galerie commerciale
plan dans neuf
au milieu des restaurants de sushi
l'enseigne française
à hay comment ça va très bien oui super
bienvenue dans votre restaurant à ya pas
de fautes d'orthographe c'est très bien
ça commence bien
alors mais à l'intérieur un problème lui
saute aux yeux est la guest
prodigieusement faut remonter ça je veux
dire décès des montagnes de produits
c'est pas 4 produits qui se balade on
est quand même c'est quand même la
marque de biscuits au japon étrangères
et on se retrouve là dans nos propres
établissements avec un minimum syndical
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas bien ce
restaurant eric vannier la penser dans
le moindre détail si le personnel et
japonais ici tout doit rappeler la
france entre les cuivres de villedieu
les poêles ou les photos du mont saint
michel on se croirait presque en
normandie c'est bien fait c'est simple
parce qu'on sait conforme aux manuels
un décor savamment étudiés dont le
moindre détail étaient consignés dans ce
pavé de 200 pages la bible et eric
vannier ne peuvent pas faire ce qu'ils
veulent non non non on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour faire un restaurant depuis les
cuisines jusqu'à la salle en passant par
le personnel à partir du moment où vous
voulez faire un concept et le faire
respecter quoi les dans tous les détails
aujourd'hui c'est important eric vannier
a prévu d'en faire une chaîne de
restaurants des franchises qu'il espère
vendre en quantité mais pour y arriver
il va d'abord devoir convaincre les
journalistes et surtout cette critique
gastronomique très influente je suis
ravi de vous rencontrer ah désolé c'est
dans l'autre sens je suis critique
gastronomique et directrice du magasin
c'est elle qui fait la pluie et le beau
temps dans le monde culinaire au japon
si le concept lui plaît le public
pourrait bien suivre
alors pour la séduire le businessman a
sorti son atout charme la mère poulard
en personne
ah bah ça y est tu es un
rando c'est le l'habit de lumière ses
nièces famille qu'il est déguisé pour
l'occasion et il n'hésite pas à la faire
passer pour la descendante de la célèbre
cuisinière je la trouve très
ressemblantes avec son aïeule
effectivement jeunes
c'est elle que l'on retrouve sur les
paquets de biscuits de la marque
mais eric vannier compte surtout sur son
autre star
[Musique]
sa légendaire omelette
ou
la critique manque de tomber en pâmoison
elle est énorme j'ai jamais vu une
omelette aussi grosse ah non j'ai jamais
vu ça
exceptionnellement la recette a été
adaptée aux goûts asiatiques l'omelette
ici n'est pas cuite au feu de bois et
elle est surtout moins baveuse mais
apparemment
la célèbre critique est conquise
c'est bon c'est très savoureux et c'est
goûteux
à mon avis ça va plaire aux japonais ah
oui j'en suis persuadé pour éric gagné
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
je pense vraiment que les japonais vont
adorer ah oui car elle est vraiment mais
vraiment grosse et délicieuse
voulait trouver bonne c'est ça
non mais vraiment je n'en ai jamais vu
une aussi belle et surtout une aussi
grosse ah oui
avec son feu vert de la presse eric
vannier va pouvoir vendre beaucoup
d'autres franchises à cet homme
monsieur mac a souri le pdg du groupe
numéro un de la restauration japonaise
c'est lui qui a acheté la toute première
franchise et c'est un peu comme s'il
s'offrait un bout du rocher
le mont-saint-michel ça fait rêver les
japonais aux cognon et la mère poulard
ça représente tout ça voilà que
rencontre le monde arabe d'abord il va
rester au japon pour faire beaucoup de
mère poulard et après leur un voyage
gratuit là bas
il est japonais n'ont pas fini de se
régaler d'omelette
eric vannier a prévu d'ouvrir 600
restaurants identique en cinq ans dans
toute l'asie de quoi gonfler un peu plus
son chiffre d'affaires estimé à près de
30 millions d'euros
[Musique]
et pour le monde certains sont prêts à
toutes les folies
il y a 6 ans sylvère a tout quitté pour
pouvoir réaliser son rêve
l'emportent par
cet ancien chauffeur routier a
démissionné de son travail mais surtout
il a fait déménager toute sa famille
près de 300 km depuis tour et s'il a
acheté cet ancien presbytère c'est juste
pour pouvoir se dire un jour
rejouer le mont-saint-michel déjà or ce
passionné rêve de pouvoir admirer le
mont saint michel depuis son lit
seulement voilà pour l'instant il faut
se pencher par la fenêtre à six
kilomètres de là entre le lampadaire et
l'arbre le mont saint michel en modèle
réduit pourquoi pas la chance d'avoir le
monde juste à côté quand on le voit
d'une des chambres en profiter un peu
trop loin pour silvère
qui aimerait bien en profiter dès le
réveil alors il a eu une idée
positionner une série de miroirs pour
pouvoir projeter l'image du monde
jusqu'au lit conjugal mais tout n'est
comme moi d'accord manière et de façon à
ce que je vois je vois l'angle si je
trouve une fixation un projet très
ambitieux et complètement fou pour anita
sa femme
je suis sceptique quand même accepté
qu'on écoute on va tenter on verra bien
mais ça vaut le coup d'essayer
mais s'il vers edu gens obstinés je
pollue l'eau ce matin son mont saint
michel il le verra du lit quoi qu'il en
coûte
et à faire des trous dans les murs
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui ferait pas pour avoir
seulement ça mais celle en vue
depuis l'âge de 7 ans sylvère est obsédé
par le monde il a lu des dizaines de
livres sur le sujet
ça c'est bien moi c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
gdg les bonnes idées quand même bah
ouais il faut qu'il faut que je gagne de
l'anglais ça j'ai passé d'angle et pour
pouvoir vivre son rêve jusqu'au bout
sylvère est même allé jusqu'à changer de
métier
[Musique]
mais un jour bonjour
cet ancien chauffeur routier est devenus
guides de la baie du mont-saint-michel
tac vous êtes toujours d'accord pour
aller faire un petit tour dans la baie
du mont saint michel
bah ma foi je vous avais je me suis même
parti allez
pour son groupe de touristes il a prévu
ce jour-là une boucle de trois heures
autour du monde alors là ça va glisser
un petit peuvent marcher doucement vous
faites des petits pas et beaucoup de
tenue à votre camarade d'à côté comme
sas irak et glissant radio tu as un
talent
avec silvère les visites n'ont rien
d'une promenade de santé c'est donc le
gentil ça va tout le monde impeccable
avaler c'est sympa au départ quand ça
passe entre les orteils
s'il a gardé sa gouaille de camionneurs
il ne regrette pas son changement de vie
on vit dans un dans un tel endroit à tel
endroit tellement magnifique on filtre
est très difficile de le sort de
s'enlacer c'est pas possible à mes yeux
c'est que j'aurai merveille à sa sueur
froide c'est tellement beau que c'est de
la magie c'est certain ça démarre
aujourd'hui sylvère fait partie des
quarante guide de cette immense baie du
beau jeu grande comme cinq fois la ville
de paris
quand on voit nos labos juste derrière
aussi aux en amorti quoi me faire une
balade comme ça c'est magnifique
sous ses allures de plage paisible 7b
est en réalité très dangereuse
[Musique]
alors on ne descend pas ressort ressort
toutefois que le descend pas ces flaques
d'eau où les enfants pataugent peuvent
se transformer en piège approchez vous
s'il vous plaît
à ces foutus je suis parti les sables
mouvants en moins de 5 secondes le guide
se retrouve en sable et jusqu'aux genoux
ceux là sont sages y en a certains vous
allez arriver au thorax en moins de 10
secondes voilà là sachez les points
croyez moi bien voilà regardez bien là
je peux toujours tiré atteinte à la
dînette je suis dedans je suis dedans
terminée le vrai risque des sables
mouvants c'est de rester bloqué pendant
que la marée remonte c'est alors la
noyade assurée est impossible de
s'extirper de la les pieds piéger en
devient aussi lourd qu'une voiture il ya
des gens qui me disent mais pourquoi pas
mettre à baudrier à la personne appelée
l'hélicoptère avait fait remonter ça
c'est une bonne idée ça ça c'est pas
bête ça l'hélicoptère va monter de 8
mètres en gros c'est la longueur de la
teste à gré l'on va même pouvoir voir ce
qu il a bouffé la veille le mec mais va
gueuler d'après comptant le gazier
croyez moi bien c'est fortement
déconseillé qu'est ce qu'on fait eh ben
il va falloir inverser le processus
c'est-à-dire essayer de faire
redescendre au qu'on va avoir tout
autour de soi d'accord
reprendre du mouvement en tournant
gentiment sans forcer à elle c'est
magique et voilà c'est la magie du verre
là bas
vous servir le mont saint michel c'est
le théâtre des plus grandes marées
d'europe deux fois par jour la mer à 10
km de là en cercle le rocher
cet après midi pour le groupe c'est
marée basse mais dans moins de deux
heures ce sera le processus inverse la
mer va remonter et submergé toute cette
baie lamari comment ce monsieur raison
attention là la marée des gens très
remonté
aujourd'hui elle est pas mal aujourd'hui
elle est arrivée relativement bien c'est
à rentrer ici sur la voie rentrer là
c'est foutu mais là bas on est mal il va
falloir courir courir courir du côté les
herbus la bon voilà non les gens ne se
rendent pas compte elle est belle la
plage a avoué on a même eu un jour
trouver des américains qui avaient
planté leurs toiles d'autant que l'on de
la sélune par là c'est quand même assez
unique quoi ils étaient surpris en
voyant l'hélico arrivée à la mairie de
meaux ne s'arrête pas dans ce top les
dompteurs notre groupe a le temps de
rejoindre la terre ferme
mais pour les touristes partis sans
guide le danger guette ce soir on attend
la plus grosse marée du siècle grâce aux
travaux de désensablement la mer gagne
de plus en plus de terrain
par endroits l'eau va monter jusqu'à 3
mètres au mont saint michel les
gendarmes et les pompiers doivent
s'assurer qu'il ne reste aucun touriste
égaré dans la zone ça va venir très très
très très proches et les gens s'en
aperçoivent pas ils sont là ils peuvent
penser à autre chose comment les
beaucoup de moments plus il n'est pas
impossible qu'on trouve voyez pourquoi
derrière là des gens qu'ils soient sont
accrochés pour cent pas que la mer va
arriver jusqu'à toi ok alors on y va
chaque année une vingtaine de personnes
se retrouvent pris au piège encerclé par
la marée
le commandant et ses hommes vont
inspecter chaque recoin au pied des
remparts du mont-saint-michel ivoiriens
ne porte que la rejetant en encan route
l'abbaye une autre équipe ballet la zone
avec des jumelles
des reçus pour visite
en dernier recours un hélicoptère est
toujours prêt à décoller
ce soir des curieux sont venus assister
au spectacle
ce qu'ils attendent c'est cette vague
qui arrive avec la marée
le mascaret une sorte de mini tsunami
selon la légende elle arriverait la
vitesse d'un galop de cheval mais en
réalité sa vitesse n'excéderait pas les
10 km heure pour les gendarmes c'est le
signal qu'il faut évacuer
les sa casquette
en quelques secondes la mer recouvre
entièrement toute cette étendue de sable
l'eau va maintenant on est très vite
jusqu'à atteindre par endroits trois
mètres de profondeur
voilà
le pompier ont fait la démonstration
touristes
voilà en une seconde un danger croît pas
loin et il ya les trous on est emporté
vraiment impressionnant là il ya deux
minutes des petits l'autre côté il ya de
l'eau sur trois
l'eau va continuer à monter pendant une
heure les touristes vont devoir aller
admirer le spectacle d'un peu plus haut
un spectacle qui vaut le détour les
travaux de désensablement commence à
faire effet ce soir pour la première
fois depuis 134 ans le mont saint michel
redevient une île
un spectacle devant lequel yens galt on
n'a pas le temps de s'attarder
comment ça
à déployer au maximum
avant de finir sa journée l'adjoint au
maire doit gérer un énième problème qui
le contrarie
la voir partout
les poubelles mans saint michel avant
pour se fondre dans des corps elle
ressemblait à ça mais aujourd'hui pour
des questions de sécurité il doit tout
changer maintenant qu'on est sous
vigipirate on est obligé de retirer sa
et mettre un sac transparent pour que
visuellement on voit s'il ya dedans
c'est franchement dégueulasse mais c'est
ce que m'a imposé
et l'adjoint au maire n'a pas fini de
râler la fin des travaux de
désensablement est prévue pour 2015 les
tensions ne sont pas près de retomber au
mont saint michel